cinq millions huit cent cinquante mille
adhérents à la cgt un chiffre qui fait
sûrement rêvé son secrétaire général
philippe martinez mais c'est un chiffre
qui remonte à 1946 à paris s'est tenu le
congrès de la cgt
le monde du travail a aujourd'hui
officiellement sa place dans la vie et
dans l'est pas au dernier recensement en
2017 la cgt deuxième organisation
syndicale française comptait six cent
trente six mille adhérents
alors quand a commencé la dégringolade
retour dans les années 70 c'est une
lente hémorragie jusqu'à 1985 date clé
cette année là le nombre d'adhérents
passe sous la barre symbolique du
million
la cgt se porte aujourd'hui vraiment
très mal et tout un symbole
la fédération la plus touchée par cette
désaffection c'est celle de la
métallurgie au lieu de l'implantation de
la cgt mais pourquoi ce journaliste
énuméré les causes de la désertion des
adhérents en 1985
les raisons de cette crise
l'organisation du syndicalisme mal
adaptée à l'évolution des nouvelles
structures des entreprises
en second lieu la conjoncture économique
en période de chômage
la combativité des salariés est plutôt
faible et bien souvent les luttes ne
débouche pas enfin troisième cause la
bienveillance relative de la cgt à
l'égard du gouvernement
les années qui suivent confirme ce
constat le nombre d'adhérents continue
de baisser pour arriver en 1993 aux 2000
lyon le secrétaire général de l'époque
était alors prié de s'expliquer sur les
plateaux télé c'est qu'effectivement
depuis une bonne quinzaine d'années le
le mouvement syndical et la cgt en
particulier et quelles que soient ses
efforts et quelles que soient ses
initiatives n'est pas parvenu à créer
les conditions pour imposer des
résultats j'allais dire sonnants et
trébuchants qui conduisent les salariés
à dire bah oui c'est vraiment le moment
de se syndiquer au début des années 2000
le syndicat reprend des petites couleurs
avec 600 mille adhérents en 2005
campagne de communication nouvelles
techniques de recrutement par exemple en
pleine manifestation étudiante contre le
cpu
le syndicat ne se privait pas de draguer
les jeunes étudiants cette jeunesse est
disponible pour l'action collective
nous avons le devoir d'y faire écho en
allant à leur rencontre
mais depuis 2012 le nombre d'adhérents
est de nouveau en baisse en 2010 est la
cgt pouvait compter sur six cent trente
six mille adhérents une désaffection qui
ne touchent pas que la cgt
si 30% des français étaient syndiqués en
ils n'étaient que 11% en 2016
[Musique]